hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a British supernatural horror
drama series called In the Flesh
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the show is set in a dystopian world
where a mysterious phenomenon has caused
dead people to suddenly reanimate as
zombies they crawl from their graves and
start hunting down normal humans for
their brains and flesh the episode opens
up in a supermarket in the city of
rorton where a woman named Elisa
Lancaster is Scavenging alone she is a
member of the human volunteer force or
the hvf doesn't really roll off the
tongue a group dedicated to saving
humans from zombies right then she hears
a noise and turns around only to notice
a zombie-like girl devouring a man's
flesh the site terrifies Lisa and she
tries to run but ends up tripping over
another body the bullets in her gun also
run out and to make this situation worse
all the lights inside the store go off
at the same time as Lisa struggles to
find her way out she unknowingly appears
in front of another zombie Kieran Walker
and meets her Doom following this the
show Fast forwards by a decade where the
world is returned to normalcy the zombie
epidemic has been contained by the armed
militia and the once infected people are
being treated at the partially deceased
syndrome or PDS Treatment Center that
one rolls off a little nicer Kieran is
also among these patients and he still
has flashbacks of the time when he used
to kill people duck I'm pretty sure I
ate a guy's dick once however the doctor
reassures him that the flashbacks are a
positive indicator and they show that
his damaged brain's cognitive circuitry
is being restored he then informs Kieran
to be prepared to meet his family the
latter is hesitant as he believes that
he is not ready to leave the facility
yet but the doctor assures him that the
medications will help him adjust to his
new life when Kieran walks out we can
see a long queue of people suffering
from PDS waiting for their turn for the
checkup on the other hand in the city of
rorton kieran's parents Steve and Sue
are trying to sell their property
probably to get away from the anti-pds
local residents unfortunately the
customers refused to buy the house
stating that they wish to go somewhere
more isolated after the customers leave
kieran's younger sister gem a member of
the hvf leaves the house after declining
to accompany her parents to pick up
Kieran from the PDS facility it seems
like she hates her brother for the fact
that he killed people to fulfill himself
during the zombie State at the PDS
Treatment Center together with his
roommates Kieran attempts group therapy
he expresses his crippling guilt for
killing Lisa but one of the guys Cuts
him off and advises him not to feel bad
about it since they had to kill to feed
themselves he also mentions that they
had no control over their minds at the
time look man we all ate dicks in the
following scene gem arrives at a bar
where she is welcomed by Bill Macy a
commander in the hvf some more members
also arrive for their weekly meeting
following this bill provides them with
Patrol walkie-talkies and explains that
they will have to kill the rodders AKA
zombies even if they are on medication
on the day Kieran is supposed to be
picked up by his family he wakes up from
a horrible dream in the morning just
then a guy walks into the room and
informs him that it's time to leave
outside his pair parents arrived to pick
him up and they are soon escorted toward
his room as the family finally reunites
they shed tears of joy Steve comments
that despite everything that has
happened they are ready to move on from
it on the way back home Kieran inquires
about a graffiti God bless the hvf but
he doesn't get an answer later the
family arrives home and hurries inside
to avoid any unwanted attention
unfortunately an elderly woman from
across the road spots them through the
curtains it's that zombie boy in the
next scene a town council member surely
stops by The Walker residence and
informs Sue that she is well aware of
Kieran returning home she reveals that
she works for the PDS treatment facility
and teaches them how to inject the same
medication that Kieran requires every
day without it he might revert to his
untreated condition surely then hands to
a taser suggesting that she use it on
Kirin if he ever becomes violent
especially if she values Steve's dick
later that evening Kieran is confronted
by his sister Jam who angrily asks if he
is a demon she doesn't want to accept
him as a brother because of all the
atrocities he committed in reply Kieran
says that after his best friend Rick
passed away he became lost the
depression eventually took his life
which continued even when he turned into
a zombie later at night bill is informed
by one of his men that there is a rotter
hiding in the city Furious he grabs his
gun and heads out to kill the suspected
zombie meanwhile gem overhears
everything through the walkie-talkie and
suspects that they are talking about her
brother so she immediately rushes home
and informs her parents that bill is
coming for Kieran following this The
Walker family arms themselves with
weapons and hides Kieran after a while
bill and the other hvf members arrive in
front of their house but instead of
barging into the Walker residence they
pull out the elderly woman who had
spotted Kieran earlier she has also
revealed to be a PDS patient who is
still showing symptoms of the zombie
virus her husband begs Bill to leave her
alone but the evil Commander executes
the poor woman in front of everyone next
bill returns home finds his wife crying
when he inquires about what happens she
reveals that their son Rick who had been
killed in Afghanistan has been found the
news elates bill but when his wife
reveals that Rick will return home as a
PDS patient his expression changes the
following morning Kieran wakes up and
stares at a picture of Rick pasted on
the room's wall he then puts on some
skin color makeup and his contact lenses
before going downstairs to his parents
on his way he enters Gem's room and
thanks her for saving him the previous
night but she simply asks him to go away
before slamming the door later as the
family is conversing in the kitchen gem
arrives and brings up the ceremony that
she is about to attend with her mother
curious Kieran asks about it and despite
the parents trying to change the topic
gem reveals that the ceremony is about
honoring the people who lost their lives
during the rising in other words
honoring the people who got killed by
zombies like Kieran during their
untreated stage shortly after Jim and
Sue leave to attend the ceremony and at
the same time Steve gets a call from his
boss asking him to arrive at work
urgently shortly after he drives away
Kieran puts on a hoodie and walks out of
the house straight to the restricted
Cemetery there while looking at his
tombstone he gets a vision of himself
coming out of the graveyard just then
Kieran notices a girl in the distance
but before he can hide she manages to
spot him she is none other than the same
girl who attacked Elisa in the
department store she introduces herself
as Amy Dyer and suggests Kieran forget
his past and enjoy his life the latter
tries to say goodbye and leave but Amy
holds his hand and takes him to a fun
park slowly they become comfortable with
one another and start playing different
games unfortunately a guy recognizes
Kieran there as a rotter and starts
chasing him away soon other people also
join in making Kieran afraid and
compelling him to run away alone luckily
he arrives back home right before his
family can find out that he went outside
like a regular Ferris ghouler later at
night when the Walker family is having
dinner Amy arrives at their door and
calls for Kieran he welcomes her inside
but when she starts talking nonsense
with his parents he escorts her to his
room meanwhile gem goes to join her hvf
team for night patrolling but one of her
colleagues Dean denies her entry he
reveals that bill saw Kieran at her
house the other day enraged gems slams
the door of the vehicle and returns home
gem is good at slamming doors on the
other hand Rick finally arrives home
with his parents and other people
waiting for him he greets them kindly
and hugs his mom before heading straight
to his room later bill takes Rick to the
local pub and tries to convince the hvf
members that his son is totally fine the
boy also starts sharing his military
stories and battle encounters impressing
everyone meanwhile Kieran walks out of
the house with Amy and heads toward the
pub to meet Rick turns out that gem told
him everything about Rick and his return
to the town in the next scene when the
two best friends finally meet Rick is
taken aback and he simply keeps shaking
hands later while everyone is busy
chatting Dean rushes into the pub and
informs everyone that he noticed rodders
roaming freely in the forest and that
they nearly attacked him soon as the hvf
soldiers hear this they grab their
weapons and head towards the forest Bill
asks Rick to join him and the latter
agrees however he also persuades his
father to let Kieran come with them
shortly after the group arrives at the
forest and begins searching for the
rotors while Kieran and Rick remain in
the car right then Kieran hears some
strange noises and follows them until he
reaches a nearby cave there he notices
two zombies an adult and a little girl
feeding on a dead sheep soon Rick also
arrives there and informs his father
about the location after a bit of a
struggle the group manages to get hold
of the two zombies but not before Dean
gets bitten by the adult one as everyone
holds their breath in horror Kieran
explains that PDS is not contagious and
so he prevents Dean from committing the
unthinkable following this bill orders
his son to shoot the zombies and kill
them immediately however Kieran doesn't
like the idea so he stands in front of
the rifle stopping Rick from shooting he
even takes out his contact lenses and
tells the group that they need to shoot
him before shooting the other two
zombies hearing this Rick finally lowers
his weapon but he along with his Angry
Dad returned home without Kieran leaving
him to wander alone in the forest the
following day Sue and Steve are waiting
for their son to arrive home as he was
gone for the whole night meanwhile
Kieran walks inside the same Superstore
in which he killed Lisa at the start of
the show after staring at the exact
place he murdered her he gets a vision
of exactly what happened that day to his
surprise he sees Jam arriving at the
store holding a gun in her hand she
notices Kieran feeding on the now dead
Elisa but cannot pull herself together
to shoot him she was put on this planet
to slam doors not to cap asses back to
the present Kieran returns home and
without disturbing his parents goes
straight to his sister's room he then
wakes Jim up and asks her why she didn't
pull the trigger on him at the
superstore gem replies that she didn't
have the courage to shoot her own
brother so she simply ran away from
there she also mentions that she lied to
everyone telling them that her bullets
ran out before she could shoot the
zombies after hearing his sister out
Kieran decides to visit Lisa's parents
and tell them the truth to bring them
some closure gem thinks it's a good idea
so she also decides to join him after a
while the two arrive at Lisa's house to
talk to her parents the poor couple
still believes that their daughter is
missing and that she will soon return
home upset Kieran honestly tells them
that he was the one who bit Lisa and
killed her he mentions that his body
wasn't in control when he did it and
that he feels very guilty about it to
this day however the grief-stricken
parents refuse to believe it they have
been living all these years hopeful that
their daughter will return one day and
bring happiness back into their lives
gem becomes emotional hearing this so
she stops her brother from disclosing
anything more elsewhere Bill expresses
his anger on Rick for not killing the
zombies as a punishment he asks the boy
to finish Kieran off stating that he is
a monster and a threat to the community
unable to deny his father Rick agrees to
get the job done soon he sneaks out of
the house and approaches a telephone
booth he dials kieran's house number but
no one picks up so Rick leaves a voice
message informing Kieran to hide because
he and his father are coming to his
house to kill him meanwhile as Gem and
Kieran are returning from Lisa's house
they notice Amy at the train station
waiting for a train to arrive Karen
quickly goes up to her and inquires if
she's going on a day trip without him
Amy replies that there is nothing for
them in the city and so she wants to go
away and live a free life she then hugs
Kieran and Promises to visit him someday
before leaving uh says Kieran I've eaten
dicks but I've never teased them on the
other hand bill is teaching his son how
to attack zombies and kill them
efficiently after the training Rick
enters the bathroom and removes his
makeup and contact lenses revealing to
his father that he is also a PDS
sufferer who is once a zombie to his
surprise Bill hugs him and asks him to
let go of everything that is troubling
him in the following scene gem arrives
home and picks up the phone receiver to
check for messages when she hears Rick's
message I'm coming to kill you boy
hoorah you must have that zombie ass boy
she immediately rushes out of the house
in search of her brother the scene then
switches to Kieran who is standing alone
at a bridge when Bill drives past him in
his car however he does not pay much
attention to Bill and returns home
unfortunately when Kieran arrives
outside his house he notices the dead
body of wreck leaning against their
garage devastated he cries for a while
and heads straight to Bill's house
despite gem trying to stop him at Bill's
house his wife Janet arrives after a
long day at work and inquires about
Rick's whereabouts surprisingly bill
says that he hasn't seen Rick for five
years at the same time a depressed
looking Kieran barges inside the house
and confronts bill for killing his own
son hearing this Janet picks up a knife
and a tax bill slashing his hands after
seeing the blood in his hands and his
own wife ready to kill him Bill realizes
what he has done and becomes ashamed of
himself however as soon as he steps out
of the house he is shot by Burton the
same guy whose wife he had brutally
killed earlier all's bill that ends bill
in the next scene Kieran walks out of
Bill's house house and finds him in the
same condition as before all alone
without wreck instead of going home he
goes to the forest to the same cave
where he and Rick used to meet secretly
to his surprise Sue arrives there
searching for him she asks him to return
home and finally persuades him by
sharing one of her tragic stories
sometime later the two arrive home and
the family reunites Steve desperately
trying his best to hold in his emotions
starts crying like a baby in the last
scene Kieran attends Rick's funeral and
watches him being buried this time he is
not treated as a rotter but as a normal
human his father bill is also buried
right next to him the episode ends with
Kieran returning home with his family
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching